one of the places i get my excitement
from oh boy it's saturday night live
baby oh i'm a huge saturday live friend
oh yes huge satellite five you know they
just returned
for its 47th season snl's back baby yeah
did you see it this past week i didn't
do you know what i would say i think i
liked the
oh gee snl what the what like
will ferrell
uh david spade okay um
i i love that but now it's just not i
think maybe trying have been hard i
don't know trying too hard man yeah all
right anyway snl's back baby all right
that's back
i don't i don't spend my saturday night
quite candidly at 11 30 to 1 a.m
watching us and i'll watch the clips on
monday tuesday what have you right a
couple days after but anyway
the the new season returns 47th season
so that means it's 20 21 47 so by 2024
it'll be its 50th season big deal big
sale so return last week you know who
the host was owen wilson
owen wilson owen wilson that goofy
looking dude
zoolander what was this thing
all right or when it wasn't
he had a thing owen wilson's like
hey hey man
he's like that's not michael jackson
he's you know i love i love the scene in
wedding crashers like i'm reading don't
kill myself books right now oh yeah okay
thanks owen anyway he was hansel so hot
right now hansel and zoolander anyway
everyone's talking about the jokes
everyone's talking about the cast wow
yeah oh that was this thing yeah wow
everyone's talking about everything
that's going on so you know what i care
about david what's that i don't care
about the money of course how much are
these cast members making that's what i
want to know how much of these funny
freaking people make him so this is how
much cast members get paid on snl pretty
interesting i want to find out what
their memory is yeah i never you know i
never really thought any idea how much
these guys are making i want to say
upwards of the hundred thousands up
there more than the facebook analysts
more yes more than some some yes some no
let's get into some of this so how much
of the cast members getting paid
something you should know is they get
paid per episode oh it's like the same
bitcoin they get paid a bit
they get paid per episode and it's based
on experience and tenure how long you've
been there aka more experience more
money each season you're there you get a
little bit more money you get a little
though you guys okay so they do about 20
episodes a year okay okay so everything
is per episode they work six days a week
start on monday clock in first thing in
the morning yeah boom they work all the
way through saturday night until after
the show is over 1am they get sundays
off and then they run it back the next
week on monday sick i got a question for
you i don't know if you'll answer i
can't answer but i know that they you
know they all write their own bits or
whatever yeah and then not all bits
make it you know yeah not so even if
your thing doesn't make it you still get
money you get paid per episode that's it
exactly okay but that is competitive
they want your bits to get on you get
more time you get more camera time they
like your stuff you get renewed for the
next season you get more money the next
season good question
it's competitive it has to be i dig it i
don't know if it's cutthroat but it's
certainly competitive but anyways they
get
they get uh paid per episode
and they get um they work six days a
week anyway let's scroll down real quick
see if we can get some of these names so
it's a girl called heidi gardner she's
sort of the bottom of the list she makes
8 000 an episode that's 160 grand a
season okay just go scroll real fast as
you're scrolling down there she is right
there eight grand an episode keeping it
moving there's a couple other guys that
have been in the show for a few years
alex moffatt mike mikey day kyle mooney
these guys get somewhere between eight
to 15k an episode we haven't verified
those exact numbers it's about 200 grand
a year but you know who we did verify
i happen to think this guy is the least
funniest guy on snl oh there he is the
least [ __ ] funniest guy but for some
reason he gets all the attention snl you
know what i'm talking about yeah on pete
david this is the number seven people
yeah
the least funniest least funny
least funny
uh he gets paid 15 000
an episode that's 300 grand a year but
he makes a lot of his money because he's
made movies i think he did a smart water
commercial the guy's making money he's
definitely made a name for himself so
respect on that i just don't think he's
that funny he's somewhat funny i think
he made me laugh before i'll fist fight
you right now david
now he's okay but not not not not my cup
of tea
michael che he does the weekend update
makes 15k same as
um
our guy pete davidson he's done at
netflix specials he's on hbo he's done
amex commercials so he's making money
outside of snl he makes 300 grand a year
15k per season then there's the ladies
there's a couple ladies that have been
around for years they are awesome
hilarious namely kate mckinnon she's
everywhere she played hillary clinton
she plays um a cast of characters who's
the person that she played
um
not um oh
god uh yes i know you're talking about
the elizabeth warren
yes she plays elizabeth warren exactly
exactly kate mckinnon she plays every
character is that who you're thinking
yes yes yes yes she's crazy talented
blonde lady she makes 25 000 an episode
that's half a million a season she's not
on this list though she's down there oh
she's down there she's down there okay
there she is
keep going there she is right there kate
there she's playing
uh uh there is
looks like that's hillary clinton there
it is right there anyway she's freaking
hilarious she also is the new face of
verizon yeah she's doing commercials for
tostitos scroll back up and you'll see
the other lovely lady cecily strong she
also makes 25k
an episode half a million dollars a
season she's done doing outside work as
well she's the new face of prego italian
sauce okay she's also doing commercials
for triscuit she gets paid 25 000 an
episode then you got the face with
michael che of the weekend update you
got colin jost he's making another 25
000 a season sorry an episode half a
million dollars a season this guy went
to freaking harvard
just went to harvard congress went to
harvard he studied history started
literature and now he's doing weekend
update for snl so it takes brains to
tell those types of jokes but you know
who makes more money than anyone who has
been around the most the longest 10-year
person on snl numero uno drum roll
please oh i know yeah yeah yeah keenan
thompson
canon thompson i think he was a good
burger back in the day
in the early 2000s late 90s he also
makes upwards of 25 000 an episode
that's a half a million a season but
he's got his own network sitcom he's
doing his keenan thing yeah he's got the
highest net worth
of any current cast member nine million
bucks you know what canon thompson he is
funny but oh they've been funnier
i mean he's not the funniest ever but
he's good yeah you've never seen this
for sure
that he does hello there mike what's up
with that he's not gonna go to hollywood
he's not gonna be a leading man in
hollywood so it's like
mom i'm never moving out i'm staying
with you type of thing i don't know
something like that i mean you can stay
with us forever
i think he's just like a fixture there
anyway speaking of networks he's the
highest net worth of any current cast
member
here's some previous cast members that
are raking in the freaking though here
are some of the
highest net worth cast members of all
time
so previous cast members of snl with the
highest net worth out there you got
chris rock
70 million bucks
got this article is it uh keep scrolling
down you had it
okay chris rock 70 million will ferrell
your boy
80 million bucks
you you're you're crazy you're i like
you man but you're crazy you're crazy
anchorman yeah yeah yeah talladegan
knights
mugatu zulu i mean
he's my nikon bro eddie murphy 85
million bucks there he is okay
mike myers then then
awesome powers baby 175
million bucks
then you got a cast member the people
didn't know that she was a cast member
of saturn live
she was on seinfeld for many years we're
talking about julia louis-dreyfus dude i
had these worth 200 million you had a
crush on julia still yeah when she was
on seinfeld and those reruns interesting
out of that era and number one on the
list by far and ain't even close
the wealthiest cast member of all time
snl
is a hoo-hoo i give you adam sandler
for the people out there i want you to
know that is adam's iconic
any impression i'm going to do
there it is does it
all day around the office
anyway
so that's that's the current cast
members what they're making and previous
cast members net worth adam sandler
taking the lead
stop looking at me swan
i used to love adam sandler when i was
12 years i wanted to be adam sandler
anyway now now he's now all the news
about adam sandler is playing basketball
yeah that's it and that's all i do is
adam yes yeah i don't know adam adam
adam sandler maybe we can do a little
duet one day who knows anyway here's my
little final takeaway
yes the cast members are making money
being on snl cool respect to you guys
it's awesome who what comedian would not
want to be on saturday live but the
bigger thing is that it's sort of a
launching pad for the rest of your
career
you're making this keenan thompson
[Laughter]
anyway it so what's what can the average
person take other than good to know what
snl people are making understand that
that starting somewhere
making 25 grand an episode is cool it's
dope yeah but there's a greater
plan for success for some of these other
guys for the welfares of the world for
the eddie murphys of the world
adam sandler's of the world mike myers
of the world where he said all right
i've got this platform i made a name for
myself respect cool that's awesome what
else can i do so when you're taking a
job how can what can how can you
extrapolate this when you're taking a
job
not only do you think short term but
also think long term is the job that's
paying you more now
going to be where you want to be long
term or is it better to sacrifice
the job that might pay you a little bit
more now
for the upside of a potential big time
job at a at a company that you truly
believe in that's something to think
about anyway that's where i took yeah um
this story with snl
i love snl that's it so it's good to
know what these guys are making they're
making a couple hundred grand a year to
as much as a half a million bucks a year
to entertain us i think it's worth it
these guys are crazy talented and then
you know especially the will ferrell's
the eddie murphys yeah those guys are
the adam sandlers of the world they're
definitely worth the hundreds of
millions of what they got going on shout
out to you guys at snl all this money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken